io che sono
io sono
credo la persona meno adatta a
rassicurare le persone
però in questo periodo strano ma vero e
proprio questo quello che vogliono da me
le aziende e gli imprenditori in
generale
qualche settimana e ricevo telefonate
del tipo si è pronto sei pronto seguii
pedro se sei un grande sei veramente un
grande sei un grande perché grazie no
perché io sono un imprenditore e lavoro
nel settore del turismo e siamo messi
male ma ci dà una mano
bisogna fare una colla insieme web come
va di moda ora e dove tu ci dai tira un
po su di morale ma su di morale a meno
ma io su di morale cioè un no detto ci
può raccontare qualche storia di qualche
storiella ma cioè l'ufo sommi un clown
cioè perché grazie lo stesso sei
comunque un grande anche grazie attacca
passato tre giorni vediamo un anno fa
dice sì pronto livello purtroppo se è
guarda e mia nonna che a2a veramente è
pazza di te grazie al 95 anni non vede
non sente nulla poi la donna cammina un
giorno sì e un giorno no però da dov'era
veramente io sono un imprenditore al
lavoro nel mondo dell'immobiliare
possiamo rovinare
siamo tutti in cassa integrazione e ci
piacerebbe fare una pole contesto zoom
almeno tucci dire un pochino su di
morale anche se mai un pezzo di lavoro
io posso farlo spogliarello sono anche
piccino scuro so quanto possa essere
utile ma che ci può raccontare delle
storie su firenze su come si è
risollevata dopo le catastrofi e l'hanno
colpita nel corso dei secoli buona idea
rosso fa meglio secondo me perché si
parla della città siamo troppo generici
non ci si può perdere
parliamo invece del singolo parliamo
della persona lorenzo il magnifico per
esempio il magnifico non il grande il
mitico i bomber cioè il magnifico
quest'uomo veste chiamati magnifico
qualcosa di grande e la raffaella suina
no
partiamo da in 9 perché lorenzo il
magnifico i libri di storia ci insegnano
anche in maniera un po formale e noiosa
che il titolo di magnifico messere
veniva la fa i signori di firenze a chi
governava una volta raggiunti 45 anni di
età
lorenzo però muore a 43 e diventa
signore di firenze a 20 quindi lui già a
vent'anni di magnifico con lui aveva
avere vinto poteva stare sul divano con
le pantofole tutta la vita e rimaneva
comunque magnifico no invece molle
strafare a tutti i nostri è uomo di
grande cultura
un uomo di grande carisma di grande
carattere
oggi diremmo di lorenzo il magnifico di
un grande comunicatore site ed ex
avrebbe fatto nel magnifico 40 minuti
più recupero dice ma noi solo 18 minuti
cioè le regole dalla l'ifo che regola
numero federalismo in magnifico
io sto alcun ora a ragionare esco fuori
anche dai cerchio rosso e quale futuro
all evento che segnò per sempre la vita
di quest'uomo la morte tragica del
fratello giuliano avvenuta con la
famosissima congiura dei pazzi no
quest'attentato ideato dalla famiglia de
pazzi un'importante famiglia di
banchieri fiorentina che con l'aiuto con
l'appoggio del simpaticone papa si suo
arto però a ribaltare il potere a
firenze
e fu così che il giorno di pasqua del 26
aprile 1478 dentro il duomo di firenze
dentro la cattedrale santa maria del
fiore si concretizzò questa congiura che
però luci soltanto in parte perché morì
soltanto giuliano lorenzo
miracolosamente riuscì a salvarsi anche
grazie all'aiuto degli amici più stretti
poliziano della mirandola addirittura
francesco nori si sacrificò per lorenzo
perché si prese la coltellata al posto
suo
se mi sono in mezzo tipo film film
d'azione no lorenzo si ferì soltanto al
collo
da quel momento dell'iri frutto tale
perché il papa si stava altro per lui
prima e lo simpatico primo scomunicò
lorenzo e poi dichiarò guerra a firenze
la situazione in italia era
completamente ingestibile serviva quindi
la giornata del campione no
nel mondo del calcio si direbbe ci
voleva la causa del fuoriclasse
e fu così che lorenzo il magnifico in
gran segreto in maniera fa almeno
inaspettata parti per napoli per
convincere il re ferdinando a dell'area
ad allearsi con lui invece con il papa
qui simpaticone si è visto prima
un'impresa insomma è tutt'altro il
semplice anche perché prima andare a
napoli e tuba alla stazione troppi di
teno dare a napoli
tu vai da in rete chiacchere di figli
treno all 8 posto per la firenze averle
fatto mezza giornata fatto tutta la
prima andrà a napoli era veramente
un'impresa in più si aggiunge il fatto
che chi ti aspetta ferdinando cioè la
bellissima abitudine di sgozzare suoi
ospiti capitoli fa venire a palazzo dice
venite venite si fa la pace e poi nella
notte coltellate ad essere amata e non
so come si tradurrà incredibilmente però
lorenzo ce la fa dopo tre mesi di
trattative estenuanti grazie alla sua
parlantina e quando si fermava quando
parti non si ferma mai
riuscì a convincere ferdinando ad
allearsi con lui invece con il papà
lorenzo quindi torna a firenze con la
pace in tasca con la pace in saccoccia
accolto come un eroe accolto come il
salvatore della patria e machiavelli
niccolò machiavelli scrive una frase
secondo me bellissima su questa vicenda
dice avendo esposto la propria vita per
rendere alla patria sua la pace questo
devo dire che lorenzo era pronto a
sacrificarsi per firenze e racconto era
pronto a sacrificarsi per la pace con
quella mossa lorenzo dette scacco matto
al papa diventando l'uomo politico più
importante del quattrocento
guadagnandosi il rispetto di tutti gli
altri grandi gli altri signori gli altri
potenti d'italia che rimasero come
intimoriti come spaventati da questo
gesto perché non se l'aspettava nessuno
pensare che i congiurati quel giorno di
pasqua lo volevano uccidere lo resero
più un magnifico e mani e facciamo un
salto avanti di 600 anni circa
protagonista della nostra storia
stavolta di pedro che sarei io vicino xi
pedrinho che c'è alla passione per la
storia quella dell'arte ama la sua città
si trova
si trova a lavorare come camera in un
ristorante però si trova bene si diverte
trovate il suo ambiente addirittura
m'iscrivevo in meno sulle magliette
arrivava il tavolo è la gente dice ai
menu o meno che eccolo nemmeno i menu e
rimaneva un credo della 20 minuti a
parla con la gente finché 11 anni piatto
tra l'altro idea geniale segna tra sotto
choc ristorante anche un bar e perché tu
svolti è improvvisamente un giorno
all'improvviso spariscono 2 mila euro
dalla tasca del giubbotto del
proprietario arriva polizia e fbi
carabinieri guardia di finanza
l'ispettore gadget sherlock holmes erian
tutti dopo una settimana di indagini
qui pedro viene incolpato se stavate
perché io ma io ero a lavorare le prove
le prove non ci servono se state perchè
te tu sei troppo furbo
tu sei troppo svelto tu sei troppo
veloce e quegli altri quegli altri
solventi avrebbero mai potuto farlo
quindi se sto sveglio di che sono anche
un lato si va via e mandarono via
tornare a casa disperato piante is
bright e strappa pelli vestiti i miei
genitori i parenti in generale gli amici
iniziano a fomentare mi no denuncia lo
rovinano chiuda gli rifiuti li locale
lavora bianconero ha tutte le carte in
regola per rovinarlo
io sentivo questa zona sentivo che c'era
qualcosa che non andava i miei
sentimenti non erano allineati
completamente no è importante ascoltare
proprio corpo perché ci manda i segnali
giusti a dopo un paio di giorni meno
uscì dicendo ma perché io mi devo
concentrare su di lui perché io devo
concentrare il mio focus su sentimenti
totalmente inutili come l'odio la
vendetta il rancore la rabbia se ti
metti non servono a nulla quando qui la
cosa veramente importante
sono io sono io che mi davo di sollevare
da questa situazione
la svolta per me quella volta fu
accettare la sofferenza e non rifiutarla
accettarla come come fosse un sentimento
normale siamo esseri umani ovviamente
istintivamente rifiutiamo il dolore sia
fisico che mentale
ma nel momento in cui capiamo che la
sofferenza può essere trasformata in
energia positiva alla voce ferma più
nessuno
diventiamo imbattibili e di è così che
mi sento quando faccio io mi sento
sotto un animale mi sento un leone mi
sento sto tirando fuori al cento per
cento
il mio carattere e la mia personalità ma
sono arrivato a questo punto a questa
consapevolezza
soltanto grazie ai fallimenti e alle
sofferenze precedenti non esisterebbe
nessun wii pedro oggi se non avesse
fallito prima come studente poi come
calciatore soprattutto come calciatore
perché ce l'avevo le qualità per
arrivare ce lo diano a tutti per noi
smetterla mitchell aveva davvero mi
manca niente però me la facevo sotto tra
un campo mi tremava alla camera il
classico giocatore del giovedì
io giovedì ero fortissimo avevo la
domenica facevo schifo
il mio allenatore mi diceva per
motivarmi è un uomo in bocca un altro un
sam ha visto che oggi mi si para davanti
alcuno mentre facevi devono mancio e
questo tutti concetti pensieri e io ho
elaborato anche di recente nel nel video
che ho fatto per il primo giorno di
scuola dell'apertura delle scuole dopo
la pandemia un giorno per me è molto
importante e mi era stato chiesto di
dare un messaggio agli studenti e
ragazzi ma che messaggio potevo dare io
io ero che ero uno studente migliore io
che se gli studenti vedessero in esame
di maturità butterebbero via il
telefonino
quindi bisogna e dia un messaggio i
rientri nelle mie orc e quindi oltre a
dire questo concetto della della
sofferenza ho cercato di dirgli di
iniziare fin da subito a porsi le
domande interne in maniera corretta
per me le domande interne hanno fatto la
differenza quali sono i tuoi talenti
quali sono le cui qualità cosa ti piace
in cosa puoi essere diverso vediamo qui
ripetere allora come esempio quali sono
le sue qualità le sue talenti allora la
pace è simpatico mediamente simpatico sa
parlare sa fa parlare fatta con la gente
e smart e veloce e svelto in america
nando da in california mi dicevano your
smart
intanto però qualcosa si trovava
cosa ti piace mi piace piace cinema
piace l'arte mi piace il mondo del
teatro e sono innamorato pazzo della mia
città mi piace raccontare storie sulla
mia città
e cosa puoi essere diverso da quegli
altri io di lavoro faccio cioè affitto
un appartamento a turisti tutti si
limitano i miei concorrenti a mettere le
foto del divano della cucina della
camera da letto sui vari portali io
potrei iniziare a fare dei video
gratuiti chiaramente facendo conoscere
firenze dando informazioni utili sulla
città che magari convertire le persone
che guardano i miei video in clienti per
l'a ppartamento svoltava divise
proposito svoltato non sono un grande
operazione fallimentare chiaramente però
in un cervello era partito aveva
iniziato a produrre qualcosa poi lascia
fare se sono buone idee o cattive idee
tra l'altro cervello è partito è entrato
moto con queste domande interne poste
nella maniera giusta e questo per me è
stato molto importante
mi rendo perfettamente conto che il
periodo che stiamo vivendo un periodo
difficilissimo forse il più difficile di
tutti e le parole abbiamo detto oggi
tutti sono molto belle ma possono essere
anche fini a se stesse per le persone
hanno grossi problemi da risolvere e
soprattutto problemi reali e imminenti
l'altro giorno ero sul ponte vecchio è
una signora una gioielliera mi si è
messa a piangere davanti quindi posso
raccontare tutta la storia dei medici
dai primo all'ultimo però la signora
sarà difficile alterarla sonno
però io sono convinto che se superiamo
tutti insieme questo periodo allora
veramente non avremo più paura di niente
abbiamo la possibilità adesso di
diventare i magnifici davvero proprio
come lorenzo che quella volta seppe
trasformare a suo vantaggio
un episodio drammatico come la morte del
fratello ma se ci pensiamo bene cioè
tutte le grandi imprese del passato
nascono da delle delusioni perché pippo
brunelleschi quando fece la cupola
tagliando tutto liscio come l'olio
ci arrivo dalla commissione di sistema
che è il progetto è semplice da ben 300
bravo dopo inizia lavori valpiani soldi
cappuccio e brioche vai e divertiti e fa
la cupola glie lo bocciarono il primo
progetto bocciato l'idea tranche di
pazzi
va a casa iudica chiave per benino pippo
e butta via la chiave
lui è tranquillo sereno sapeva che
quella era stata giusta il suo sogno era
giusto per les chi aveva il sogno giusto
era solo questione di tempo
infatti poi ha realizzato in soli 20
anni
credo la più grande opera architettonica
della della storia quindi questo vuol
dire vuol dire che i grandi del passato
ci insegnano che i risultati più
importanti si ottengono dopo delle
delusioni
dopo delle sofferenze perché quanto è
bella giovinezza che si fugge tuttavia
chi vuol esser lieto sia del doman non
c'è certezza
grazie